[inaudible].
Thank you,
David.
Thanks very much.
Can everybody hear me in the back?
So I get to talk about my trips,
but you don't,
it doesn't,
it doesn't seem fair.
Um,
so I'm going to just talk for about 10 minutes and just tell you a little bit
about what this book's about and then I'd love to take your questions,
um,
uh,
and,
and let your interest,
uh,
dictate the path that we take this afternoon.
Uh,
first,
thanks.
Thank you very much for coming.
This book,
uh,
is a real departure for me.
Um,
those of you who know me as someone who writes about food might think it's a
little weird that,
um,
turning to secondary clicks,
but in my head there's a,
there is some continuity as well as change.
And the continuity is that I see my writing about food as part of a larger
interest in writing about nature.
And you know,
the way we eat affects nature dramatically more than anything else we do
actually,
in terms of changing the landscape of,
of,
of the planet and the atmosphere.
And I mean it's,
it's one of the,
it's your most powerful engagement with the natural world.
And I've always been interested in that engagement.
And,
um,
we use nature and plants,
especially for,
for many things.
Food is an obvious one.
Um,
beauty is another,
but something we almost all use plants for that I've always been kind of curious
about is to change consciousness.
Most of us today probably use the plan to change the contents of your mind or at
least the feeling tone in your mind.
Uh,
you know,
whether it was coffee or tea or a or a cigarette or a cannabis or whatever it
is.
I mean,
this is something we do and every culture on earth does it,
uh,
with the,
with the one exception that proves the rule,
the [inaudible] do not have any plant drugs,
but it's only because none of them grow where they live as soon as they go
somewhere else they get with the program.
Uh,
so it's been a long standing interest and,
and to me,
it's all part of that story about this,
this fascinating engagement we have with other species,
uh,
that defines us.
And reveals a lot about us.
Um,
so I,
so that,
and I wrote a little bit about cannabis in botany of desire and,
uh,
and I wrote a long piece about growing opium and my garden,
back in the 90s,
and I've written about medical marijuana.
So I had this interest.
And then along comes this new research which I began reading about.
Um,
in 2010 I read about a really interesting odd study where researchers at Nyu and
Johns Hopkins,
we're giving Psilocybin,
this is the ingredient in magic mushrooms.
There were synthesizing it,
um,
to people who had cancer diagnoses,
people,
very sick,
many of them terminal in the hopes that they would have a,
what they call the mystical experience,
a powerful spiritual experience that would change their attitude toward their
death and help them essentially to die with more peace.
Um,
they were,
these were all patients who are struggling with depression,
anxiety and fear,
profound fear and the stories I,
so I started writing about that because it seemed like the last thing I would
want to do is trip when I was facing a terminal diagnosis to lose control.
Like that.
And uh,
you would,
you would presumably have a very dark experience.
Um,
so I started interviewing these people for a piece I did in the New Yorker in
2015 and,
um,
just to give you one example,
to give you the flavor of it,
I remember talking to this woman,
she was a,
um,
a figure skating instructor and in New York,
in Manhattan,
she was about 60.
She was not a psycho naut,
she'd never used psychedelics before and she had ovarian cancer and her cancer
had been treated successfully,
but she was paralyzed by the fear of recurrence.
She just couldn't function cause she thought any day now this could be back.
Um,
so she entered into this trial at Nyu and had a,
um,
a high dose psilocybin experience.
And I should explain how this is done because the image you may have in your
head of taking second,
Alex,
uh,
you know,
taking a handful of mushrooms and going to a concert or something.
This is not how it is used in a clinical setting.
It's a very controlled experience.
It's guided.
Um,
so you,
you work with two guides,
a man and a woman,
they prepare you over a course of several sessions as to what to expect.
Um,
so they'll talk to you what to do if,
if,
if the experience becomes frightening,
which it often does.
A,
and how to navigate that.
They call it the flight instructions and their,
and their main advice is,
you know,
if you see a staircase go up.
It,
if you see a door open it,
if you,
um,
if you see a monster,
don't run away,
just step right up to and say,
what are you doing in my head?
What do you have to teach me?
Um,
in other words,
surrender to the experience.
Um,
uh,
trust,
relax.
They quote John Lennon,
uh,
relax the mind and float downstream.
Um,
and that's very important advice.
And it's often the difference between a good trip and a bad trip.
Uh,
a bad trip is essentially a panic reaction against what's happening in your
head,
which is very heavy.
I mean,
you're,
you're experiencing your ego dissolving in fact,
in front of you.
Um,
and then they sit with you for the whole experience and they give you a helping
hand if you're getting upset,
uh,
are struggling and they take you to the bathroom and give you a glass of water.
Uh,
and then afterwards is a really key moment called the integration session where
they,
um,
uh,
sit with you.
You tell the story of your trip and it usually is this narrative.
It's almost like this interest psychic movie where you go different places and
you try to make sense of it and apply the lessons to your life.
So in the case of this woman,
her name is Dina Baser,
she,
um,
uh,
she had this trip and there are many elements I won't go into.
It was,
it was like six hours.
Um,
and she went into her body imaginatively and she saw this black mass under her
rib cage.
And that was her fear.
It wasn't her cancer cause that wasn't in the right place,
but she saw what she realized was her fear and she screamed at her fear and you
have to see this woman.
She's very timid,
small woman.
And she said,
get the fuck out of my body.
And it did.
It disappeared.
The black mask was gone.
And afterwards she said,
I realized during that experience that I can't control my cancer,
but I can control my fear.
And that distinction meant everything to her.
And one of the hallmarks of the psychedelic experience is that whatever insights
you have during it,
have a force.
The likes of which you've never experienced.
These are not just opinions or insights,
they're revealed truths.
This is something William James,
a long time ago writing about the a mystical experience called the noetic since
it's a very uncanny thing.
And it's what allows people to change that if they,
if they think,
say they're trying to quit smoking and they have some epiphany that,
gee,
my breadth is really precious,
I should not ruin it by smoking.
Suddenly that'll be so strongly held as a belief that they can actually stop
smoking.
So anyways,
so that's the kind of experience that I was learning about and I became
fascinated to understand the neuroscience behind it,
what's going on in the brain when people are taking one of these trips.
And we now know some interesting things about that.
If you're interested,
I can talk about that.
And also the history of it.
Like what happened the second deluxe in the 60s,
that they became so stigmatized that,
um,
research stopped.
There had been a very productive period of research all through the 50s that was
yielding really promising results in the treatment of alcoholism,
in,
in dealing with people who are dying,
depression,
anxiety,
obsession.
And then after this moral panic that hits the culture around 1965,
um,
nobody studies it anymore.
Uh,
the funding dries up.
Scientists are a little embarrassed by it.
And,
uh,
and we had an unprecedented situation where a promising line of scientific
investigation,
uh,
was stopped.
Um,
that never happens.
And we lost 30,
35 years of research into psychedelics.
Thankfully it's resuming.
And my book is very much about the renaissance.
Even though I go back and look at the history and,
uh,
figure out why we had this panic reaction about them,
and try to look at them in a very matter of fact,
way as interesting tools,
interesting tools for understanding the mind and for healing the mind.
Now we haven't proven all this.
Um,
there's still more research to be done.
we're kind of in phase two and there's face,
there are three phases to FDA,
drug approval.
Um,
but so far the results have been remarkably encouraging.
it is one of the most powerful psychiatric interventions that the researchers
they've ever seen.
And we're in a situation where,
um,
mental health care is so broken in this country.
It's failing to reach half the people who need it.
Um,
the last major innovation where the,
where the SSRI antidepressants in the late eighties,
there really hasn't been anything since then.
Um,
and,
uh,
so we need some new ways of thinking.
And,
and along comes this powerful old but new innovation and,
um,
and the research is,
you know,
it's being privately funded for the most part.
Big Pharma is not interested in this.
There's no intellectual property that you can control.
Um,
but a lot of,
uh,
donors,
many in the tech community actually have stepped up and are funding this
research.
Uh,
and I was just at a fundraiser where,
you know,
the last $7 million was raised and,
uh,
and so we will find out,
we'll get the real test,
the scientific test of what,
what are these drugs good for?
And then there's the question of what are they,
what value might they have for the rest of us?
Um,
because they help people who have serious problems.
But as one researcher put it to me,
they're very important for the betterment of well people.
Um,
and,
uh,
and I can talk a little bit about that too.
So as part of this,
because it's sort of my brand to do emersion journalism.
You know,
when I wrote about the cattle industry,
I bought a steer when I,
um,
uh,
when I wanted to learn about architecture,
I built a house.
So of course I had to experiment and,
um,
and I,
I found some guides underground and there is a thriving community of underground
guides in America who could give me an experience very much like the ones at Nyu
and Hopkins and,
and they were,
you know,
transformative experiences,
some of them,
um,
some of the most meaningful experiences,
my live life and the idea that a molecule could occasion that is,
um,
to me still kind mind blowing.
So I'm going to though I've given you lots of leads and things you might want to
follow up on and uh,
I'm happy to talk about anything.
Um,
I advise you not to talk about your own experiences.
I want to welcome the Google microdosing club to today's event.
Um,
anyway,
so yeah.
Question.
All right.
So,
uh,
I don't want to be the devil's advocate here,
but it's
this idea that we're going to,
we're going to give somebody this drug,
they're going to have this transformative experience.
And then it's going to change them.
I understand how that makes sense to me,
but the idea that that change would necessarily be for the better.
Yeah.
That like person comes back from a trip and decides they're going to quit
smoking.
That's great.
But like why doesn't a person come back from a trip and decide they need to like
killed her neighbor?
Like right.
What we're,
how do we break the cemetery there,
set and set it.
So
one of the,
the,
one of the important features of second Elyx is how little the experiences for
ordained are dictated by the drug itself.
The drug is like an unspecific mental amplifier.
And so your expectation and intention is very important to what happens.
And one of the things that happens in the preparation is that the guide is
helping you set an intention.
Like,
I want to quit smoking,
I want to confront my mortality.
Um,
and you will usually have an experience in that realm.
because that's what you've been primed to have.
Um,
could the drugs be used for evil?
well we have the case of Charles Manson Manson.
Apparently.
We don't know that all the details,
but used LSD on his little posse of,
of,
uh,
what would become murderers,
um,
and they are,
the drugs are incredibly suggestible and that you could imagine a charismatic
figure using them that way.
Then now that the CIA sought to use in that way to the CIA,
had a very active research program in the 50s.
The same time all this university work was going on in the 50s to help people.
The CIA was trying to weaponize,
uh,
LSD and Psilocybin,
and they thought they went through a series of different paradigms.
One was,
um,
uh,
you would use it as a truth serum.
People would,
couldn't,
could tell you the truth if you gave it to them in interrogation.
People said crazy shit,
you know,
and it didn't work.
Uh,
there was no truth in that.
And,
um,
uh,
and then they thought,
well,
we could use it to,
uh,
have foreign leaders.
We can dose them and they would do embarrassing things that might work,
I don't know.
And we don't know how far they got with it.
And then the other one was his mind control,
right?
That you could use this drug to control people's minds.
As far as we know,
that didn't work either,
but we don't know for sure.
Um,
uh,
and we shouldn't put too much by them.
So I think it all depends on your therapist and how the,
how the situation is.
People don't generally go have violent episodes after psychedelics in general.
The experience tends to be one where you discover that love is the most
important thing in the universe and this hallmark card platitudes suddenly
becomes this profundity and,
um,
and it is a profundity,
but we've heard it so many times that it's been now there's an interesting line
between the Banal and the profound and psychedelics definitely works on that
line.
So,
um,
I think we should be mindful of that possibility.
But I,
I don't think,
we certainly haven't seen anything like that.
There've been a thousand dosings of volunteers since this next,
this new wave of research and there has not been a single adverse event.
Uh,
no psychotic breaks,
uh,
no jumping out of windows.
Um,
but there,
there's no question that people can do stupid things on psychedelics as they can
on alcohol and,
and any number of drugs.
So thanks very much.
You.
Woo.
Do you have any theories of why our brains are wired to react to things from
plants and some guy?
And are there any things when the animal came to that do the same thing?
Well,
animals do,
uh,
like plant drugs also.
I mean,
we,
we have many cases of,
I mean,
if you've had a cat and never given them cat nap,
um,
no,
I meant like any venoms that,
uh,
oh yeah.
One of the second Alex I,
I,
I'm experimented with is something called five Meo DMT.
This is a pretty obscure Psychedelic,
I see a couple nods in the crowd,
um,
that,
uh,
is the smoked venom of the Sonoran desert toad.
Somebody figured that out,
right?
I mean,
what a species.
Huh?
Um,
uh,
so,
um,
but you're the,
but why are we wired for,
this is a really interesting question.
So the way the drugs appear to work in the mind,
um,
is that they,
they,
they bind to your serotonin at one particular serotonin receptor that's very
common in the cortex and they start a cascade of effects.
That's what neuroscience is.
And they really don't know what's happening for a while.
And,
um,
but that,
that in turn eventually downregulate something called the default mode network
when they,
I'll tell you what that is cause it's very important actually.
And um,
and it explains a lot.
So when they first started doing fmri imaging of people's brains on
psychedelics,
they would basically inject you with psilocybin and slide you into the MRI
machine and you'd have what could be a very scary experience.
And um,
and then they took these pictures and they expected to see lots of extra
activity because there's such fireworks in the experience.
Um,
but they,
they were very surprised to find that in fact,
this particular network went quiet.
And this is a network that's very active when you're not on task.
Okay.
It's in a CSR relationship with the attentional networks when you're like
working or something like that.
But when you're asked to just lie back in an MRI machine and they're trying to
get a baseline,
this lights up and they were like,
why is that?
What is it doing?
Well,
this appears to be the part of your brain that is active.
When you're mind wandering,
when you're ruminating or worrying or reflecting on yourself,
it's a center of self reflection.
It's also involved in time travel,
the ability to think about the future or the past.
And it's involved in theory of mind.
This is the,
uh,
this is the term for the ability to think about the mental states of other
people,
central to compassionate and imagination and things like that.
And lastly,
it's involved in something called the,
um,
uh,
the narrative self or experiential self.
And this is kind of where you knit together what happens to you,
uh,
at any given moment with the story of who you are,
based on who you've been and who you want to be.
And it's kind of where we sustain that story that our sense of self depends on,
um,
and so this network,
so if the ego has an address,
it's in the default mode network.
This is,
this is what the research shows.
It's really interesting that this is what gets down regulated,
uh,
during the experience and,
and it,
and it chimes with the experience of ego dissolution.
People report on a high dose experience.
I had an experience on a guided silicide been trip where I felt my sense of self
scattered to the wind,
like a blizzard of post its and then I looked out and I don't know what,
who's the eye he was looking out at this.
I mean there was a split in consciousness where I could watch myself then get
spread over the landscape,
like a coat of paint out there and I was fine with it.
This other self was fine with it.
Um,
and it was this kind of very unperturbed double consciousness that could be hold
this thing.
And I realized I'm not identical to my ego and what was going.
And that's a very important insight,
um,
to acquire I think,
and very useful.
Um,
but what was going on in my brain was the default mode network was going offline
for a period of time.
The sense of self dissolves and then something else happens,
which is other networks in the brain,
which normally would only communicate through this hub,
start talking directly to each other.
And there's a map in the book of the brain on us on a placebo and the brain on
psilocybin.
And one looks like the route map of American Airlines and the other,
it looks like the route map of some like little commuter line that you know,
and it goes to 10 places.
And um,
uh,
so new connections form.
And what are those new connections?
I mean,
that's the interesting question,
uh,
is that your,
say your hippocampus talking to your visual cortex and so you start having
images of things that you,
that you fear or desire.
Um,
is it the basis of hallucination or is it perhaps the basis of a new metaphor or
new insight or new meme?
Um,
we don't know yet.
That's the next step is to really understand that.
So,
um,
these are temporary changes in the brain.
Eventually your ego kind of reconsolidate.
Um,
but having had a glimpse of that other way to the whole experience is very
powerful.
Uh,
and in my integration session,
I said to Mary,
who is my guide?
I said,
well,
okay,
I've had this amazing experience of ego dissolution.
And I realized I'm not identical to my ego.
I can have a little distance on it.
But I said,
my ego is back in uniform and on patrol.
What?
So what good is that?
And she said,
well,
basically you've had a taste of another way to react to,
to life.
A little less defensive,
a little less trigger happy,
and you can cultivate that.
And I said,
how?
And she said through meditation and Meditation is kind of how you keep alive,
the psychedelic experience.
It makes you a very good meditator.
Um,
although I know you're not supposed to say good or bad meditator,
but,
um,
being trapped in that language.
Um,
so that's,
that's kind of a,
you know,
real shorthand of what we understand about the neuroscience.
The,
the,
the neuroscientific investigation of this phenomena is absolutely fascinating.
And for me,
that chapter of the book was,
um,
you know,
the,
the most challenging,
right?
Well,
not the most challenging,
but one of the most challenging and fascinating to learn about.
So thanks for your question.
Thank you.
Hi.
Um,
I,
so I have heard,
uh,
reverse that amongst,
have been able to achieve if somewhere thing to a psychedelic trip.
Um,
do you know anything about what that entails or if it's like,
if there's any research that
yes,
to it being a strong,
or it's,
I mean,
there's anecdotal research is really interesting.
So one very relevant fact.
At the same time,
we were doing this imaging work on Psilocybin in the human brain and there was
another researcher at Yale,
uh,
imaging the brains of very experienced meditators,
people who attend thousand hours of meditation experience and they would go into
the Fmr Ri and meditate and their brains looked identical.
They also had this suppression of the default mode network.
And of course that is the state of kind of selflessness that people report
coming out of meditation.
In terms of the monks.
Um,
these are people with really long experience meditation,
a meditation and that they can almost,
it will probably quiet the default mode network.
There's a famous story about,
um,
Ron Doss,
Richard Alpert,
who was Timothy Leary's,
a collaborator and went during the Harvard psilocybin project in the early
sixties.
He,
this guy went on to become,
uh,
a guru basically,
and he's still alive.
He's in Hawaii and he was very interested in psychedelics and then found Hindu
religion and he went to India and he told his guru about lsds and his,
and his guru said,
um,
I want to try it.
I want to see what happens cause you're telling me you're reaching this
spiritual plane on this drug.
And that's my,
that's my territory.
And um,
so,
uh,
Ron doss apparently gave him 600 micrograms of Lsd,
which is a beyond heroic dose.
And that's what the guy wanted.
He said,
give me as much as you have.
And,
and the,
the monk or whatever he is,
he's a guru.
I guess takes it and nothing happened.
Is this true?
I mean it's,
you know,
Ron does tells the story in and swears that it's true,
but,
um,
but it goes to your point,
there are other ways to achieve the same effect.
Um,
psychedelics are probably a shortcut to becoming a really good meditator,
but my guess is we will find at some point that all the disciplines,
the spiritual disciplines that share this sense of,
uh,
of transcending the ego,
um,
are doing the same thing in the brain.
Um,
that that is where that's happening.
And I'm thinking of sensory deprivation.
You know,
if you get into these tanks,
sensory deprivation tanks,
they're sort of coming back.
There were a thing in the 60s,
um,
uh,
or fasting or prayer or the right kind of music and,
and breathing exercises.
One of the psychedelic trips I had involved,
no drugs,
something called holotropic breathwork.
It's,
it's based on a yogic breathing exercise where you essentially hyperventilate
you,
you breathe really fast,
you exhale more than,
than you inhale and you enter a trance state.
It's,
it's the most uncanny thing.
And my guess is that hyperventilation is starving the default mode network of
oxygen,
um,
and reducing the activity there.
So this is all areas to be explored.
We may find other ways to achieve the same thing.
Um,
but I think it's all connected.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Hi.
One of the interesting trends that I've read about blogs and whatnot is the rise
of microdosing time.
For those who don't know,
a microdosing is taking small doses of psychedelics,
a somewhat regular basis,
a smoke,
far too small to actually caused any sort of trip and proponents of microdosing
claim that it can help with things such as depression and anxiety,
improved mood,
improved creativity.
I'm wondering if you got a chance to investigate microdosing at all in your book
and if you get a sense that some of the renewed research interest for high dose
experience might carry over into researching whether microdosing is clinically
significant or not.
Excellent question.
Um,
so microdosing is a very interesting phenomenon.
As the questioner said,
it's taking a sub perceptual dose with often with LSD about 10 micrograms every
third or fourth day.
And the reason you don't take it every day is because it would lose its effect.
Um,
the drugs kind of cancel themselves out at a certain point.
many people anecdotally report a success with this,
that it's kind of a brain tonic and it,
and it does help with depression.
There's a wonderful book written about it if you want to follow up by Ayelet
Waldman called a really good day and she's someone who struggled with depression
and uh,
for many years and found more relief on,
on this regime of microdosing then,
and she's been through the whole Pharmacopeia,
I'm sure.
Um,
the reason I don't spend a lot of time on it and the book is that there isn't
yet anything beyond the anecdotal reports.
They're interesting.
They're really provocative,
uh,
and they're being systematically connected.
If you go online,
there's a guy named James Fadiman who was one of the first generation
researchers whose advising people on the protocol and soliciting reports and
getting this interesting data set,
but it has not been trialed the way these,
the large dose silicide Manhasset.
I hear that these trials are about to happen.
And so we may get some really solid information on whether microdosing works.
The fact is though there is such a strong placebo effect with psychedelics,
um,
there's so suggestible then it's very easy to see how it would work.
Um,
just the very idea that you're taking a small dose of Lsd probably would have an
effect.
Um,
but is it a pharmacological effect or a placebo effect?
That's what we remains to be learned.
Um,
so,
you know,
I'm,
I'm skeptical about it.
Uh,
I,
I do want the research to happen and this interest in,
in macro dosing,
if you will,
is has stimulated people to fund some research,
some of which will be underground,
some of which will be above ground.
So I'm very excited to see what they come up with.
Thanks.
Thank you.
Thanks for being here.
Today.
Wasn't pretty famously said that LSD was one of the things that differentiated
apple from Microsoft and Johnson that too.
Yeah.
And at this organization,
uh,
we selected,
oh,
apocryphally Eric Schmidt,
the CEO,
because he was,
the candidate had been to burning man as an external observer.
I'm curious,
what are your observations about the intersection between psychedelics and,
and the technology or the tech industry?
It's a really interesting relationship.
Um,
so Steve jobs famously said too,
it had been formative to his intellectual development and,
and I thought it was him,
but maybe it was Wazniak who said that a windows would have been a much better
product,
had gates,
uh,
ever taken LSD.
It was like a really mean thing to say.
I think the gates and gates immediately said,
but I did,
but it didn't work.
It must not have been enough.
Um,
so,
um,
and I thought this was the beginning of the tech community's interest in these
drugs.
And because it's very current,
I mean,
you know better than I,
but I mean,
I've talked to lots of people in Silicon Valley and it's a big part of the
culture right now.
Microdosing macro dosing.
There's,
I mean,
I know one prominent tech company that uses it and their management training,
um,
you know,
LSD.
Um,
so it's,
there's a lot of,
you know,
a lot of interest there.
And,
and,
and it is the tech community,
as I said,
this funding a lot of this research.
Um,
but it turns out that,
um,
engineers had been interested in Lsd back in the fifties and that there's this
very interesting episode before Timothy leary and the whole 60 psychedelic story
that we think we know so well.
There was this research period and,
um,
there was this very interesting character who's kind of a counterpart to leary
named Al Hubbard.
And I tell his story in the book,
he's very mysterious figure.
He's got,
he's involved with the oss,
which became the CIA.
He's playing both sides of many worlds.
Um,
but he had a vision in 1951 that told him he could be involved in a major
civilization change.
He realized it was LSD.
He went to Sandoz were,
uh,
which own the patent on it.
It was a Swiss pharmaceutical company persuaded them to give him something like
a liter bottle of LSD,
which probably is enough to trip a third of the population of earth at that
point.
Uh,
I mean,
just an incredible amount,
which he keeps buried in death valley at his place.
And anyway,
he's a great character.
He's so much more interesting than Larry.
So He's,
he becomes the Johnny Appleseed of LSD and,
but he's got a different theory.
He said he was at kind of a conservative guy.
He wanted to turn on the elite,
so he was going to do captains of industry,
uh,
you know,
engineers,
artists,
um,
and people in the church,
the Catholic Church.
And he would go around with a Satchel tripping people,
members,
legal.
It was legal then.
And,
and he became,
and it became a very gifted guide,
so he has his eye on the tech world as one of the places where you could have
this multiplier effect.
So he turns on a couple engineers who are working at a company called Ampax,
which is actually one of the first silicon valley companies in the 50s.
They make magnetic tape on,
which as you know,
all computer information was stored,
but also video and sound recording.
He had 40,000 people in the valley before it was called Silicon Valley.
And,
um,
and the head of strategic planning,
he turned on and another guy,
and actually Ampex for awhile was going to be the world's first psychedelic
company.
And,
um,
but the,
uh,
the president was Jewish and Al Hubbard was Catholic and he kept bringing in
crucifixes and things and the,
and the president said,
go ahead.
And,
uh,
so,
but anyway,
so these engineers though were so taken with this experience that they left the
company,
a group of three or four engineers and started a big research,
uh,
something called the International Foundation for advanced research.
And they were doing a lot of psychedelic research.
And I've always been interested in as to why engineers in particular had such a
strong reaction to this drug.
And I talked to,
I talked to a couple of engineers about it and Wa,
and you can tell me if this chimes with your sense of things,
but this guy,
this one guy in particular told me that,
um,
oh,
and the are some of the early chip designers.
We're into lst.
It's very hard to design a chip without a computer.
But of course,
at the beginning you had to,
and you could hold this complex three d structure in your head,
uh,
with the help of,
the drug.
And this guy said,
oh,
and one of the,
sorry,
one of the early people at the International Foundation for advanced study who
was tripped was someone you probably know if you know your history of your
industry,
but a Doug Angle,
Bart,
right?
Who invented,
you know,
the mouse and the interface and email.
And like everything,
right?
There was this mother of all demos.
Well,
that guy got LSD from those Ampex guise and under the influence they were doing
on creativity study,
he invented something.
Then it wasn't that profound.
It was something he called a tingle toy to teat to toilet train boys and was
something you could like aim a stream of urine and it would make sure things
happen.
Okay.
It's not quite the,
you know,
the mouse,
but it was pretty cool.
But prime the pump,
you know.
Uh,
so anyway,
where was I?
So,
um,
this,
this engineer I was talking to said,
well,
the problem if you're an engineer as opposed to a scientist,
scientists can,
like their goal is to reduce problems to the simplest terms.
But engineers are faced with an irreducible complexity and number of variables.
So the challenge is different.
The challenge becomes finding pattern and psychedelics,
one of the things that happens is you find pattern where you didn't see it
before.
Um,
and that he thought was why so many engineers found this a useful tool.
I think that's fascinating.
I think there's John Mark,
I'm wrote an interesting history about silicon valley and the 60s,
and he,
and there's some very good stuff on,
on drugs and he interviewed jobs about his experience.
But um,
uh,
yeah,
it's part of the tradition.
You're your end.
Thank you.
You're welcome.
Hi.
Um,
so you talked a little bit about how like every culture in the world has
experienced this to some degree or is integrated into their,
their culture.
And I'm curious from a sort of anthropological perspective,
cause I imagine there's a huge range and the way that,
that these drugs are,
are applied,
right?
It's a select few or it's open to everyone or it's ritualistic or it's ordinary
or whatever.
Are there other sort of cultural patterns that can be yeah,
to do store associated and um,
you know,
from,
from the drug use within those coffees?
Good question.
I actually,
yeah,
we
think we have a lot to learn from the traditional use of these drugs.
So we're going to stay on psychedelics.
And um,
there are lots of plant drugs that are not that controversial like caffeine,
although in some cultures they might be.
Um,
but psychedelics have been used for,
it looks like several thousand years.
It appears that the ancient Greeks,
um,
all the writers you've heard of participating in an annual ritual that involved,
uh,
what,
what seems to be a psychedelic,
it's called,
it was called the Kiki on a,
it was an annual,
right,
uh,
in honor of diameter harvest related.
Uh,
it was called the the l e l e l e,
U s Eleusinian mysteries.
And everybody was sworn to secrecy about this.
So we don't know that much about it.
But everybody took this potion and went to the underworld,
had experiences of a beyond and it was very profound.
And,
and it was the only time you were ever allowed to take this drug.
We don't know what the drug was.
Um,
and in fact,
one person was caught using the drug at like a party and you know,
it was,
you know,
imprisoned or killed or something.
And it was,
it was a big crime.
Um,
the lesson,
I think the takeaway from lots of traditional cultures use is that they
recognize that these were very powerful medicines,
not to treated casually,
and that they all surrounded the use of their plant medicine,
as they often call it with ritual ceremony,
elders in attendance.
Um,
it was never careless.
It was never casual.
It was never a recreational.
It was a profound experience.
And I think when the drugs hit the west beginning and the 50,
late fifties,
early sixties,
we didn't have any container for them.
You know,
we didn't have rituals.
We just kind of like took a handful of mushrooms and went to a concert or we
drank LSD from the punchbowl.
Uh,
and um,
and I think that's why some people really got in trouble.
Um,
and so that the lesson that we failed to learn was that yes,
these drugs have an ancient lineage,
but look how they were used.
Look at what those cultures learn by trial and error,
um,
of,
you know,
and now we see it in shamanic ceremonies in South America.
Um,
there were mushroom cults in Mexico that went back.
We don't know how long,
but at least a thousand years.
Um,
but they were always taken in a group,
uh,
with guidance with someone who wasn't taking the drugs.
Um,
and,
uh,
with enormous care.
And I think that's what we lost and we need to now invent that container for
ourselves.
Maybe it's this therapeutic protocol I'm describing.
I'm not sure,
but that's the cultural work that needs to be done.
So thank you.
Sure.
Hi.
I was wondering whether in your research you'd come across the video of a debate
from 1967 between Timothy leary and Jerome.
Left at Mit?
No.
Jerome Let Ben [inaudible] for those who don't know who that recognize the name.
Jerome weapon was one of the pioneers of neuroscience.
It was one of the four authors of one of the first papers on the physiology of
perception title,
what the frogs I tells the frog's brain.
And uh,
he was also one of the most charismatic professors at MIT in the 1960s and they
held this debate,
uh,
sometime in 1967 and leary went first and he had the whole audience loled and to
going along,
he was very charismatic and uh,
let them got up and said bullshit.
I think it may have been the first time bullshit was allowed to be set on
broadcast television.
Um,
anyway,
uh,
let funds may biggest argument against taking LSD was the phenomenon of
uncontrolled flashbacks and how that could get people in trouble.
But,
uh,
as I was standing in line here,
I looked it up and it's on youtube.
Uh,
the,
the whole thing actually ran about two hours.
Wgbh,
public TV station recorded and broadcasted it at one hour edited version.
But I led an l e t.
V.
I.
N?
Yes.
Okay.
Maybe,
maybe two,
one or two teeth.
Well,
this is a good occasion to talk about risk.
Um,
so let me,
unless you want to frame the question,
but I'd love to,
I just have a,
I'll let you talk about it,
but I just wanted to ask one more question.
When you talk about food,
you almost always bring a bag of groceries.
Oh yes.
Let me tell you a little tutorial on the law.
So,
um,
I,
you know,
I was a very nervous Nelly doing these experiences.
I didn't have a lot of experience with psychedelics in college and,
um,
and even after I was really too afraid to take these drugs,
I didn't think I was psychologically sturdy enough at that point in my life.
And so,
before I dove in for this project,
I did a lot of research,
um,
as I'm want to do as a journalist to figure out,
well,
how,
what are the dangers?
Because there,
there are lots of stories you heard in the 60s,
you know,
people staring at the sun to live and go blind.
That was one story,
a scrambling of your chromosomes.
Both those stories by the way were one was made up,
the first was made up and that's been proven and the chromosome story was
withdrawn within months.
It was just really bad research.
Um,
psychotic breaks.
and that did happen.
Sometimes there are people at risk for schizophrenia that,
that an acid trip was what tripped them off.
Um,
but a lot of what was,
well let me divide it into two.
There's physiological risk and there's psychological risks.
Okay.
I'm the physiological side.
It's stunning how,
I don't want to overstate this,
but that how,
uh,
compared to other drugs that we take routinely,
how nontoxic,
relatively nontoxic classic psychedelics are.
Um,
and I'm talking about LSD,
psilocybin DMT,
um,
Mescalin.
Um,
they are,
there is no known lethal dose,
which you can't say about over the counter drugs you take for a cold or from
pain.
Um,
uh,
there are very few molecules in your brain.
They're washed out really quickly and they don't seem to affect the,
um,
you know,
they affect your brain and they don't affect other parts of,
if you have a panic attack,
your blood pressure's going to go up.
But they don't directly affect other systems.
That's one thing.
And they're also non addictive.
Um,
they're,
the first thought you have upon finishing a psychedelic trip is like,
when can I do that again?
It's actually,
do I ever have to do that again?
Um,
and because it's really intense and they're so,
they're not habit forming.
If you give the rat set,
you know,
with the,
in that experiment with the rat has two levers and one's cocaine and one's food,
and if you press it,
deliver,
he gets a dose of cocaine and they'll press until they die over and over and
over again.
Um,
you put LSD in that contraption,
we'll press it once and never again.
Um,
I mean,
imagine being a rat on Lsd.
So,
so from a,
from your,
from the physiological point of view,
they're safer than a lot of drugs we take routinely.
Um,
and I was surprised to learn that frankly,
um,
psychologically,
you know,
it's very hard to sort through the stories,
the flashback phenomenon,
which,
which I've heard reported.
Um,
I have never found any really good research on it.
and I'm still looking for it.
If anybody has a good paper on that,
I'd love to see it.
Um,
there are,
you know,
I've had,
I've kind of flashed on things that happened in my experience because they're
part of my store of psychic,
powerful psychic memories.
Um,
is that a flashback?
I don't think so cause I can get it out of my head.
Um,
but there are people who have these unbidden uh,
moments of consciousness that are,
that you know,
may be connected to what happened to them.
Um,
I haven't heard that they interfere with people's life or mental health.
but it's,
it's a,
it's a question mark.
Um,
the great danger is the danger you have drinking too much also,
which is doing stupid things,
uh,
walking into traffic falling.
Um,
all that happens on psychedelics as it happens with any powerful drug and they,
they,
it,
that's why a guide is really important.
So I'm going to look out for your body in the con in the studies that have gone
on,
there have now been a thousand dosings of people who have been screened for
mental health problems and things like that.
Um,
and there has not been a single serious adverse event.
so are there adverse events when people use the drugs?
Recreational?
Yes.
We all know people who've had really bad trips and they usually stop using it at
that point.
Um,
felt trapped,
had panic reactions,
but often,
um,
psychiatrists would,
who didn't know this territory would misinterpret a panic reaction as a
psychotic break because it sure looks like that you're having delusions,
you're hearing voices,
you know,
I mean,
to an average psychiatrist,
this would say psychosis,
but often it was a panic attack.
I interviewed Andrew Weil,
Dr Andrew Weil about this.
Um,
and he was very interested in psychedelics in the 60s.
He was at Harvard and leary was there.
And,
uh,
when he graduated from medical school in 1968,
he,
he went out to San Francisco and volunteered at the Haight Ashbury free clinic.
Uh,
and they were seeing lots of LSD casualties,
as they call it.
People coming in,
having bad trips,
thinking they're losing their mind or they're dying.
And he knew the territory really well,
having used a lot of psychedelics.
And he would come into the little cubicle was somebody who was completely
freaking out.
And,
uh,
he had on his white coat and stethoscope and his clipboard,
and he'd ask a few questions and then he'd say,
the person,
we,
excuse me,
there's someone in the next room is really in trouble.
And he lead.
And they were like,
wow,
someone's more fucked up than I am.
And they would suddenly feel fine.
It was just completely subsided.
So suggestibility is a very big part of the experience.
Yeah.
Thank you very much for coming to talk to us today.
Oh,
thank you.
[inaudible].